1100 une très précisément c'est le
nombre de fois où l'inspection générale
de la police nationale a été saisie par
la justice en 2020 1100 une saisie dont
près de la moitié font suite à des
plaintes pour violences de la part des
forces de l'ordre des chiffres en large
baisse par rapport à 2019 mais
comparable aux années précédentes
un retour à la normale entre guillemets
qui s'explique notamment par les
confinements et la baisse en intensité
du mouvement des gilet jaune et gilet
jaune justement ont fait l'objet d'une
attention spéciale dans ce rapport on y
apprend par exemple que depuis le début
du mouvement 456 enquêtes ont été
confiées à la police des polices par les
procureurs et juges d'instruction sur
ces 400 six enquêtes 295 ont été
classées sans suite soit près de deux
sur trois dans la majorité des cas
l'autorité judiciaire a conclu à la
légitimité de la force employée et dans
30 % des cas il a tout simplement été
impossible d'identifier les agents ou
d'établir l'existence d'effets et ce
sont bien ces deux derniers points qui
suscitent quelques interrogations
la réputation de l'igpn a pris du plomb
dans l aile ces dernières années depuis
le mouvement des gilet jaune mais aussi
dans d'autres affaires et justement on a
appris ce mercredi que le parquet de
paris a requis un procès en
correctionnelle pour homicide
involontaire à l'encontre de trois
policiers dans le cadre de l' enquête
sur le décès d'amadou coup mais cet
homme de 33 ans a trouvé la mort en 2015
lors de son arrestation au cours de
laquelle les policiers avaient procédé
est nu clé d'étranglement pourtant
l'enquète préliminaire de l'igpn s'était
conclue par un classement sans suite il
gpn qui n'avait pas non plus établi de
lien entre l'opération des forces de
l'ordre sur le quai wilson à nantes le
soir de la fête de la musique il y a
deux ans et la noyade de steve can i saw
pourtant le commissaire en charge du
dispositif policier s'est tenue la a été
mis en examen le 13 juillet dernier on a
appris en début de semaine là encore
pour homicide involontaire
on peut évoquer aussi mélanie ngoy gamme
gilet jaune a sommé le 20 avril 2000
neuf d'un coup de matraque à l'arrière
du crâne jugé parfaitement légitime par
le parquet sans même que la victime
n'ait été auditionné par les gpn houle
enquête sur la mort de zineb redouane
devenu selon disclose je cite un symbole
de l'impunité policière
alors il ya bien eu des policiers
inquiété dix neuf d'entre eux ont été
poursuivis en 2020 dans le cadre de
procédures en lien avec les gilet jaune
l'an dernier l'igpn a par ailleurs
proposé le renvoi 222 agents devant le
conseil de discipline des chiffres qui
n'écarte pas les nombreux soupçons de
partialité à l'égard de la police des
polices